[Musique]
7h25 comme chaque matin cet entrepôt à
croissi sur Sané est en pleine
effervescence au milieu de cette
fourmilière Aure prix en 35 ans face à
elle des centaines de courriers à
classer un premier tri a déjà été
effectué par la plateforme industrielle
courrier à bois d'Arc cette factrice
doit ensuite placer l'ensemble de sa
tournée dans des cases la disposition
suit l'ordre de son parcours afin
d'optimiser son temps c'est une adresse
36 Wilson ce sont des bâtiments donc à
ce moment-là il faut procéder à une
numérotation parce qu'on a des listes
comme ceci
après les listes permettent de faciliter
la distribution parce que en fait quand
on arrive devant des batteries de boîte
aux
lettres ici en l'occurrence on en a 60
par
bâtiment c'est pas évident si on n pas
de mémoire si on débute et ceter Audrey
procède ensuite au liassage elle utilise
des élastiques pour rassembler les
courriers en botte afin de ne rien
égarer une meilleure prise en main sur
le terrain avec une technique
bien alors moi je croise moi j'ai fau ce
qu'on appelle un croisement une espèce
de repère en fait comme ça je sais que à
partir d'ici c'est une autre adresse
pour ne pas transporter l'ensemble du
courrier sur son vélo Audray rempl ses
sacs de dépôt pour délester une partie
de sa tournée ils seront ensuite déposé
par un collègue véhiculé dans un caisson
sur différents points de son parcours
donc là on va charger le vélo par qu'on
est prêt à partir
9h30 une météo pluvieuse attend Audrey à
l'extérieur sur pantalons et vestes
imperméables sont les vê indispensable
du
facteur moi je rajoute les gants parce
que je suis plus FRIL les autres le
coffre arrière sert à stocker les objets
suivis comme les recommandés ou les
petits paquets les lettres simples sont
entreposées à
l'avant avant de devenir factrice Audrey
exerçait dans le milieu scolaire des
proches travaillant à la Poste lui
donnent l'envie de se lancer en février
2018 elle intègre la plateforme courrier
à croiss sur scène en CDD à de devenir
[Musique]
titulaire on déliass un petit peu pour
que ce soit plus facile à à
manipuler bonjour
bonjour du coup on va distribuer le
courrier
à l'escalier 1 des gestes précis et
rapides un travail de mémorisation
nécessaire pour gagner en efficacité
dans cette résidence la cliente est
absente et son courrier ne rentre pas
dans la boîte à lettres Audrey doit le
confier au gardien bonjour bonour ça va
ça va et vous ça va j'ai un paquet pour
elle est pas là oui au 11 je le trouve
super gentil franchement même j'ai des
retours des locataires tout le monde
bien c'est audreé
hein
ah là c'est le petit point
ravitaillement pour boucler sa tournée
odudr en a sous la une bonne
endurance est requise pour parcourir les
15 km quotidiens avec son mon vélo
électrique et cela 6 jours sur 7 c'est
physique quand même hein vous courrez
partout ah bah oui il faut
être
toujours en mouvement coucou
a bonjour madame bidor ça va depuis un
an et demi Audrey dans la ville
du PEC entre immeubl et zone
pavillonnaire cette factrice a tissé des
liens de proximité avec les habitants un
visage familier pour eux une présence
rassurante c'est une femme charmante à
l'écoute de tout le monde il y a des
problèmes pour deux personnes qui sont
beaucoup plus âgées que moi et bien elle
le rend service ou porte le courrier ou
je sais plus quoi et même le samedi
matin si elles ont un recommandé elle
vient ils me font des petits coucous
quand il passent en
voiture ils me disent
bonjour la semaine dernière j'ai une
petite cliente qui que j'ai croisé à
vélo qui m'a attendu à l'entrée de son
bâtiment pour me donner des un bouquet
de jquy pour me dire que ça porte chance
13h47 la journée d'udre s'achève le
temps de laisser son uniforme et son
précieux vélo à l'entrepôt un repos bien
mérité avant le lendemain de se remettre
en
[Musique]
selle